Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Astroneer
Now the storm has passed
That is good
And we have a whole buttload of compound (GOING TO MAKE TETHERS THIS TIME ?!
But compound isn't exactly what we need. We still need to go find resin. (NOT AGAIN !!)
Which means that I need to go in a direction that I have not gone before.
I've gone in most of the directions, but I'm just not 100% sure where to go
And thankfully, it is finally day again
I feel like it's been night forever
Like, the whole last episode felt like it was entirely in darkness
Which is kinda cool
But at the same time, I felt extremely lonely and isolated (you didn't feel lonely and isolated during the day time ? You're still the only living guy on a PLANET)
Have no friends
Because it seems to be kinda similar to Subnautica
I mean, all my friends aren't dead thankfully (yeah they just never existed....Thats MUCH better)
That's, that's kinda good. Except for that one guy.
My clone that died over in the sandstorm in the last episode
I seem to be abandoned here all by my lonesome
And I don't know if that's planned by whatever space station I was first launched from but uh,
It seems to be a bit of a stressful situation to put anybody in.
But at least I got this oxygen fountain!
That's it? Literally?
That's all the oxygen you're gonna give me? (Yeah and you could at least act more grateful...ya dick.)
That is nothing!
That's literally nothing! Why'd you do that?
That's nothing! I thought you would have replenished by then.
Okay, either way
I gotta try to make due with what I got
And I need more resin. And then as soon as I am able to have resin
I'll be able to make what I need to make.
Ohh I found the power and oxygen cave
Ooh, shit
Okay, but at least there's a cave in here. Is that resin? That is indeed resin
Was that the only bit of resin?
Is it just buried down beneath?
Yeah, it is. Okay.
Alright then. I'll take it. Maybe that just means that I can find resin if I just dig in random locations
But I don't, I generally don't have enough power to just be doing that willy-nilly
Resin resin baby. RESIN resin
Gimme more gimme more. Gimme fuel, gimme fire, gimme that which I desire
RESIIIIIIIIIIIIN
Oh fuck. I- OHHH that is in the cave
Whoa! That is in the cave system. Okay.
So the answer, uh, to the question that I asked: could I dig down beyond and just kinda
bore my way to the base?
Uhhh
The answer is: absolutely, yes you can!
Um
There's literally nothing stopping you (Tethers Mark...tethers)
In fact, why wouldn't you? Oh god, I'm almost out of oxygen
Oh, and I'm in the wrong place.
Oh, and I need to dig out of this fucking hole
I might die. I might suffocate. Ohh no. (if only someone told me make some MOTHERFUCKING tethers.)
Go go go go
Not far. Not far. We're not far. We can make it..
We can make it. We can make it. We can make it.
Go go go go GO
Okay
No no! Not suffocating! No no no no no no no not doin' that!
Okay, we can now research this
mmmmmaaayybeee is there enough power there?
is it just like one away? in the power department?
there we go
okay
BWWWANNNK
okay, RESEARCH AWAY
YESS!
DID WE GET IT?!
DID WE DO GOOD?
But that didn't do anything.
Copper? Oh..Oh Okay!
Alright, well I mean we got more copper here which means we get two  pieces of copper
Which is gonna be good I-I-I think anyway
I'm gonna put this organic material over there because I don't-
I think that maybe the organic material might be fuel for uhm..
fuel for like a generator or something
so that I can have power, uh- pretty much anywhere
but I don't have that YET.
Tank? (GASP) I don't have titanum
Oh that might be an oxygen tank so that I can last a little longer when I go out
which would be awfully nice and-
GODAMMIT IT'S NIGHT AGAIN!
All that aside that's not what I need right now. I've got two pieces of copper
Which means I should be able to make  SOMETHING new and interesting
right here.
So let's see what we can do..
Resin..
BOINK
Ok, so we...fuel condenser...
EH
Alright..
Research, already got that- SMELTER.
...we do need that eventually.
Vehicle bay..
OOOOOH
I DO have two aluminum!
I don't have any more aluminum to be able to make a vehicle if that's what it means
but I DO have aluminum
and that would be the most interesting thing that I can make right now...
So I'm gonna do that, I'm gonna take the aluminum that I got here..
or NO WAIT
Oh no, I only have ONE aluminum
and then I have the means to make another aluminum
through smelting
ohhh shit
ahhh shit, alright then we're just gonna doooo the smelter then!
and then we're gonna make the vehicle bay next
once we're able to smelt that red stuff over there into aluminum.
I need SO much more resin
Why don't I have enough RESIN?
Okay. I'll come back for you later!
-oh that's copper ore..erh, that's cool
I do have copper, which I would be able to make something with that
Alright, so we got laterite, we just don't have power for this,
We do need to make some sort of new power system there
Is there anything else that we can make?
I can make a beefed up solar panel, I do have enough compound for that
Okay, I do have enough compound for a beefed up solar panel, I also haaave
OOOhh copper, I do have copper, I can make a generator
Let's see what that does
L-let's just explore the concepts here
because that could be something that I-I actually do need
because my base does need power.
It cannot just run on solar alone...
if I wanna do stuff at night.
That's so cool, the fabrications of that
needs coal..I DON'T HAVE COAL!
Well, DAMNIT, that doesn't help anybody! I don't have coal
Well it was a good idea but poor execution because I'm an idiot!
well shit, I shoulda made a wind turbine
That woulda been better...
That woulda been waaay better-
God damnit sun just get up already!
There you are, you sack of lazy sack of shit
Alright so what I'm gonna do is  I'mna, I'mna - put one of my solar panels.....right there
cause that way this'll charge up a little better because now I got a lot of stuff here that needs a lot of power
aaa what I'm gonna do actually- naahh, I don't wanna do that- aaaa I'll do that, okay
I'm gonna put my solar panels on there so it charges up a lot faster,
because that's what it needs to do and I need to give it a lot more power
so those are all gonna charge very quickly, uhh what I could do
is I could grab this powerrrr
so now I got plenty of power for the roooad
AAeh I guess I could take one a these with me
I'll just take the one, alright, so I got that, get these outta here, get these outta here
so I've got compound out the wazoo..
okay, I don't think I've gone in this direction before
or maybe I have and I'm just mistaken with my life
okay so I'm gonna head out in this direction and I'm gonna get some more material
I'm pretty sure that's where I carved out some resin, so no more there
there's gotta be something over here..of value to me
I'm pretty sure that sprinting consumes more oxygen but I should be able to find some on the way
Unless I'm just completely unlucky
I mean I see an oxygen fountain over there which should be able to help me.
I've got plenty of power to be able to suck it outta there
and another cave system over there so I shooouuld be golden
Probably not! Ohhh please make it, come on,  little more
Just little sips of air, not a lot of air just little sips
boobity boop boop boop boop boop- wha really? OOH because I needed to fill my bar okay
So I'm gonna go down to the cave system and preferably
I would find both resin, more oxygen and  also, another research item-
YEP more oxygen! Plenty of oxygen gotitgotitgotitgotitgotit
getitgetitgetitgetit good
goody goody goody good
Okay so, ah, resin, perfect! So there's gotta be more resin over here somewhere
Yess there is, okay, carve my staircase and, get my resin at the same time
Yes please thank you!
So it literally, resin must be just everywhere underground I just have to go dig it out
Nice nice nice..
NIICE
nice
okay so I'm gonna be smart I'm gonna carve my way out of here first,
and theeen I'm gonna do everything I need to do-
OOH more aluminum, okay
later-ite later-ite later-ite later-ite, lots of aluminum to be able to smelt stuff
okay full there but that's okay, I'm gonna dump this power..
take that there, okay got that? Alright good
got plenty of oxygen, need more stuuuff
whoaa
eefe
eugghe
aww man, that is horrifying what IS that? *idk Mark*
What is that? *once again idk Mark*
EUUUEGEHGAAHH
okay, I don't know what that is...oh, I don't think I wanna know
oh my god, euugh
so many goopies!
so many weird underground cactus things
OH WHAT IS THAT OAHH!!!!
OH IT'S PULSATING!!!!!
IT'S GREEN!!!!
IT'S GLOWING!!!!
IT'S PULSATING!!!!
EEUGH
ohh that's not- oh TH-THAT'S NOT GOOD IT'S ATTACKING ME okay that's lethal!
Okay, not good not good, okay
Hydrozine, I don't need that I need resin which is up there
I'm just going this way because there's, there's umm...there's oxygen up there
NOO that's not oxygen that was a lie okay that's a probl-OH thank goodness
Ho boy!
HO BOY!
okay we're good we're good we're good okay we got it, we got it, we got it okay where am I?
Where did I pop out?
Oh! Right here!
I didn't get nearly as much resin as I wanted
Alright, so there's gotta be more resin, there's GOTTA be, right?
Ok! So I've got enough oxygen and I've got some
uh, aluminum ore to be able to smelt down and make some aluminum
because then I'm gonna be able to make
a vehicle bay! I've got just enough resin to be able to make another one
or maybe I need just one more stack of resin
but either way it's fine because what I'm gonna do is
Imma experiment and Imma continue to dig down near my base and
prooooobably we'll find re-Waaaaaaiiii fuck it
probably we'll find resin. If I'm not mistaken.
I might be entirely mistaken, but I'm pretty sure I'm not mistaken.
Ok. Hebehdoobie. Put this on the
stop lookin in the way, goddamnit get outta the way.
ok
Buhthere... Buhthere
Smelt it up baby!
Yes
YES
YES..........shit
this got in the way...
...uh
What?! Aw! Goddamnit it wasted one of the aluminum because there wasn't enough space on it! D:
Aww goddamnit! Well that's stupid...
Alright, whatever it doesn't matter, I'm gonna make another one of theeese
Thshssss, *strange whale sounds* shit. Alright I need more resin.
So what I'm gonna do because I need more resin, I definitely need more resin.
I am going to ... dig. I'm going to dig a whole lot!
and I'm just gonna keep on digging
till I fiiiiind something
Ok, you know what, I'm gonna make somethin else
Solar panel would be nice, wind turbine!
I could make a wind turbine. Yes! I can make wind turbines
cause that's gonna be good because that means I'm gonna be able to
get power, when I'm not here.
That's good. Ok. That is good.
Ok, made a wind turbine
I can put that riiiiiiiiight...
over here...?
Yes
Come on wind! Blow! Blow! Wind blow! *Mark attempts to summon wind powers...*
Alright, fine that didn't work. But what I can do also
and I forgot about this
I can make-oh! I can have a little
mini wind vane on ME?!
Oh that way I can get power from solar
Yes! That's good, ok
that's good. Because that means when I'm on the go
I'll be able to get-ooooh that's not good.
Ok, I'm gonna make this real quick. I'm gonna make a
battery, which hopefully
is gonna mean I can carry more power with me
Yes I can, and then imma get in mah shelter
In IN IN IN. THANK YOU!
Oh boy.
Ok so!
This is good! I have extra power generators
on my backpack AND
I built a wind turbine
for...why is the wind not blowing?
BLOW WIND, BLOW!
WIND!? BLOOOOOW
Wind can you blow?
Why you no blow?
Why is, that should be blowing. Like, extra hard
It's currently winding up a storm
Why is it no, why is that not working?
That should, that should be working at every capacity
THAT'S A WIND TURBINE!
It's clearly wind!
Unless its some sort of alien not quite wind that we don't understand.
But no! That's OBVIOUSLY wind. It should be working!
So it's a little disappointing that the wind turbine
is not blowing right now because that should be
generating a lot of power
But the other good thing that I've got
is I've got a mini wind turbine on me!
...thaaat doesn't seem to be spinning either but
ya know, hey, beggers can't be choosers
So what I'm gonna do right now
is I'm gonna go explore
I'm gonna go as far out as I can
Just because I wanna see what I can find in terms of other things
Like I could go out and find resin, and there's resin right here which is kinda convenient and
and I can get that, but also I should I know for a fact that I should be able to get, uhhh oxygen on the way
and I should be able to get all that stuff and I should be
pretty well in set, like, in that department
So lemme go, HOPEFULLY I'll find some oxygen
If I don't this is gonna be a short trip
WELL I THINK THIS IS GONNA BE A SHORT TRIP HUH
I may have done goofed real hard, oooh
may have done goofed. Oh might've goofed. Oh seriously goofidge is happening
Oh no, oh no. Goof
Ooh goof, goof real hard
Please cave, please have
oxygen, cave usually have oxy-YES! OHMYGOD YES! Slidy slide
Yes! Slide down baby
Sliiiiiiiide all the way!
Oh boy, Ok. So I've gotta go in this cave and gotta find more oxygen
even though this seems to be the scariest cave that I've seen yet
I love the way I slide down these things
pretty cool. Soully radical bruh!
Fuck
Is that the, yeah that's the bad one
Ok, what's down there, oh my god that's terrifying
Whoop not goin that way! Wooah hey woah hey woah!
DON'T DO THAT TO ME!
Well either way that's enough for now. I've got resin I've got everything
If I need space, I'll dump the resin
and just go on with my life. But for now I've got enough
that I can keep goin.
What I'm looking for is I'm looking for other interesting things
Interesting landscape, I'm looking for interesting research opportunities
I'm looking for pre-made, rare materials that could be valuable to me, out in the field
I'm looking for pretty much anything and everything
and I should not be sprinting should I...
Nooooo I should not. So what is this?
Literally, what is this?
Is that a giant deposit of compound?!
Oh yeah it's compound! But it's hu-
it's MASSIVE. Ok I'm not gonna harvest from that just yet
Oh my god! There's another one over there
So if you go far enough out, you're gonna find
these literally huge deposits of these
materials.
That's not compound is it......that's resin!
That's a giant resin deposit, isn't it! I bet it is!
Ok that's nice... but how do I get all the way out here?
and how do I bring it all the way back to my base?
unless I'm just gonna be constantly extending my base out farther and farther and farther, till I
get to the deepest reaches of this area
I AM OUT OF OXYGEN
I AM FAR AWAY
I'm not OUT of oxygen but I'm about
to be out of oxygen,
SLIDE, BABY, SLIDE!!
Oh boy, Ox-o-gen?
oxygen?
Oh, thank goodness,
No stop sliding, you're too cool! C'mon stop!
Got oxygeeeeeen and, BOOP
Ok that should be enough, there is more over there, let me just grab that anyway. Just in case, because I need to be able to get out of here. k, got that?
OK, good, well that should be enough
Now, I'm going to get out of here, from this horrifying place.
They call a cave...
Boopity, boopity boop, Ok back on the way, I can't
even see where - there it is - theres home!
WAAAY, over there. So
What I- what I- what  I think about this
There's got to be a way...I can make the vehicle bay
No I can't cause I used up all of my aluminum
Aww shit, I'm an idiot. Ooookay
can't make the vehicle bay, because I did stuff with
the aluminum that I shouldn't have done
okay but either way I can - uh.. I can
extend my base out, I can continue to extend
my base out-which would be an option
I just don't know if that would be the best option
So, what the hell is this? WHAT are you
Are you pulsating like everything else in this goddamn planet?
Oh, you are aren't ya?
Eughh, EUGH, OH GOD,
Its like lotus BOOB! EUGGH
EUGH, that's horrifying to look at
Eugh, eugh
Why is everything on this planet
disgusting? I-I think this game
is randomly generated - I am pretty sure anyway,
God, everything just has to be
fucking disgusting! One seat
I don't know what a one seat would do- but imma
make it because I have plenty of compound,  so I
don't see what the problem would be. Wait maybe-what if
I put this over here? *ding ding ding*
Oh, maybe? No, that does nothing
Thats not creating any power
Ok but either way, I got the one seat here
*chuckles* What does this do?!
Wait-wha, what does this do?
This does nothing why-why is this here?
Why did I build one chair? *I don't know you tell me Mark*
Something to perch upon so that I don't feel
so lonely at night. Something to ponder
my thoughts with. So I got plenty of resin. So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make another,
take this off of there, put it there
I need to build...I need to build... not that not that not that... not that... I need to build a vehicle bay
I've got some aluminum but not enough of it
So I gotta go back in the cave
I'm not going to end this episode until I get this vehicle bay
Because I said I would... and I just had to keep my promise
Okay, just going into this cave because it's awfully convenient to where I am.
*Mumbles* Compound?
I need Aluminum so I need Aluminum ore or anything of the like.
Ooo shit!
YEE
We're going down into this thing...we're going deep, we're going deep baby!
Okay is this Aluminum? No that's Hydrazine
Not what I needed... Oh No...
OH MY GOD! Oh how deep would that go? *That's what she said*
What, is this planet just hollow?!
Holy shit... Eugggh there we go that's what I needed, aluminum, here we go
Oh jeez eiiighugh,
get some power
Okay so we need to get out of here!
*singing* Got a limited window OH MY GOD I almost fell
HOLY shit okay! * Singing * We're fine, we're fine, everything's fine
everything's fine everything is hunky-dory and fine
I love life
I love being down here
How did I get here, where did I go?
Oh no which way ohhh jeez
Ohh I'm lost aren't I? Ohhh I'm lost I'm lost I'm lost
I am lost
PLEASE let me out... PLEASE let me out
OHH Boy! Woah, what is- ohhhhh kay I guess I'll research this I think
Let me out please
I don't even think I'm going the right way
NO I AM DEFINITELY NOT going the right way
But I gotta thi- oh there! Up there! Okay that's good
But I need to get more oxygen before I- no I don't actually
The, uh, the entrance is, uh, immediately out of here
Sooo, babbity boo, if this is the right one, which it might not be now that I think about it
Maybe this is a different entrance. No?
Yes okay we're good
Okay, wooo, okay
So we got what we needed, we got aluminum, resin
So we should be able to smelt up more aluminum, at least two of 'em
which is good
and then I'm gonna research this monstrosity whatever it is
and we should be good to go
You research that, I'm gonna go over here and put the aluminum here
Oh no I'm gonna smelt it first
Tra-trade Platform?
Trade platform?
Who am I trading with?
Is that why I'm down here, just to be able to make money?
Oh
Oh okay
Okay, gonna make a vehicle bay
HUHBOOSKI
YAAAAY
It just melts into existence
That's frickin awesome
Okay, it's got no power though
Cause for some reason the wind turbine don't fucking work
I don't know why
WOOH look at that wind look at it
Hey, hey woah, hey
WOOOH LOOK AT THAT WIND TURBINE
That's awesome
Heh, yeah
Okay how much resin do I have I got two resin
Okay so I guess I can make it all the way out here, I already have this prepped and ready to go
so I might as well
Alright
Babbity boop boop boop boop boop AND BOOM
Okay so trade platform...
I NEED ALUMINUM?! GODDAMMIT I THOUGHT I HAD ALUMINUM
Fuck
Okayyy so ehhhh alright you know what? I'll, I'll worry about that in a future episode
I'm pretty sure I'm going to need the trade platform because...
I'm hoping anyway, that I'm gonna be able to trade out for materials that I need and I won't have to constantly go
hunting for them
But the vehicle bay is here...
And as soon as the sun comes up which should be just a little bit
It'll get power but it needs a lot of it
So, what I'm gonna do is, I'm gonna go back into the caves real quick
although I seem to be getting a low frame rate for some reason
Let me save, I also gotta hop in my pod and save
I'm also gonna make some more solar panels here just to speed things along
Preferably
This is all gonna go pretty quickly
I need to make another one
aaaand shammbooski
Okay so that should maximize the power, yeah that's going quicker
So as soon as this gets enough power it should have enough
to be able to make what it needs to make
and get what it needs to get
and then everything should be hunky-dory.
Okay woooah Rover?
*gasp* Rover-rover?
All it needs is compound?! *gasp*
I can make that!
I WANNA MAKE A ROVER!
OHH I just used up the last of the compound that I have
but I know I can get TONS of compound
There's PLENTY of compound around here
I GOTTA GO GET COMPOUND!!!! * as you walk past three pieces of it :D*
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK!
Boopity boop boop boop boop boopboopboopboop
gimmegimmegimmegimmegimme
gimme good gimme good gimme good gimme good
Gimme aaaaall good
More more more please, need more, need more
More more more, come on you got more
You got one more stack in ya? Oh I know you got one more stack somewhere
Yes! Yes, four stacks, okay
And then I can also get...
Cause I didn't know...
What is this?
I-it's something weird
Okay, but I got four stacks of it which means that I should be able to make the Rover
And then maybe... I'm gonna need to put the chair on top of that
It's entirely possible, I don't know 100% but I'm gonna try it because I like to try new things
Woopedoop
Oh fuck didn't mean to do that
Woopedoop woop woop woop
Okay aaand shabooski
aaand shabooski
Okay, here we go!
I'm making- I didn't even see what else you could make
Why did I just automatically default for the Rover? *who knows?*
I don't know I'm an idiot *got that right*
Weeeell shit there we go!
Can I put a chair on it? Can I put a chair on it?
*chuckling* Uhh is this gonna do anything?
I don't know if that's gonna...
Suuuure
Uh okay
Can I... Can I get in it?
WHAT?!
THAT'S SO COOL!
OH I can plug in!
How do I- How do I extend the grapper-doo?
OH THAT'S SOOO COOL!
How do I- I don't- ohhh man controlling it is a little foreign to me
Ohhh gosh
There's no backing up in this is there?
How do I hook it up? How do I hook it up?
I don't know how to hook it up.
There we go, okay, alright there we go
Yes!
YES!
YES!!!!
I CAN PUT A STORAGE ON THIS!
I can...
*gasp*
OH THAT'S SO COOL.
THAT IS SO COOL.
I CAN PUT STORAGE ON THIS AND I CAN FUEL UP AND I HAVE...
OH I CAN PUT EXTRA BATTERIES ON IT!
*voice cracking* Oh that's so cool!!!!
Oh my god I've got a ROVER!
Ah man I wonder how much- how much- I'm gonna take it on a test ride
Whoops sorry ripped that out
Okay, so...
Not a...
Not a LOT of power...
Not a lot, but some decent range and waaay better speed than I was getting out of my feet
Oh that's awesome
Does it provide- it provides me oxygen too!
It does, doesn't it?
I think it DO!
Oh that's SO cool!
AGHH, pothole!
EGH, FUCK
That is- this is the coolest thing.
This is literally the coolest thing.
I love this so much!
Oh this is so cool.
So anyway, that is awesome
But that is all the time that I got for this episode
I'm gonna figure this out...
more later
I also seem to be getting some low frame rate here and there
but that's something that's just a sacrifice of what we're gonna deal with
So, I will get that later
But uh,  for now, this is frickin awesome
I love this a lot, I'll try to figure out the low frame rate in just a bit
But either way...
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below
And as always, I will see YOU
In the next video!
BUH-BYE!
*Outro Music*